I got to go to Sundance this year,
and Sundance was kinda..
everything that I thought it would be.
(sad music)
So many dead dogs..
And I went to one of the afterparties,
where I was being totally cool and charming.
(music)
And I got to talking to this very rad Asian girl.
Hey, I just..
I just wanted to say, you were really great in Ant-man.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah,
You know, I've always wanted to get into acting,
but um,
My parents said, "Asians don't make it in Hollywood."
What?
It really struck a chord with me.
Because the feeling radiating off of her
was what I used to feel,
every time I watched a movie,
or I saw a show,
or even when I sat in an assembly in high school.
There was always something about
being just an audience member
and not a performer that made me feel weird.
Like, I wasn't where I belonged.
Like, I wasn't doing what I was supposed to be doing.
So hearing her say that..
just broke my heart.
Dude, you should totally pursue acting,
it's never too late.
No, no, I've--I've got a really stable career
in marketing and advertising now..
So?
If you know that's not what you want,
then fuck it!
I mean, you should totally chase your dream!
(nervous giggle)
And I knew she wasn't going to.
You know, I could see from the
look in her face she wasn't going to,
but it still..
it still just like, completely broke my heart
that she had been discouraged from
her dreams when she was a tiny child,
like, so many people I know aren't pursuing
what they want to do because of discouragement
from their friends, or their family,
or society's institutionalized racism and sexism.
Sidebar, let's change that.
(ding)
And I hate to break it to you,
but we all die.
So what exactly is the point in spending your life
doing something that's not your calling?
And sure, maybe this industry in particular
is very hard, and it's very reliant
upon luck and opportunity,
and being at the right place at the right time,
and working very hard for years
and with potentially no reward,
but if you love what you're doing,
and you know what you're doing
is what you were put here to do,
then how could you be doing something wrong?
How you make money
and what you pursue as your career
don't necessarily have to be the same thing.
Whenever people tell me like taking a risk
isn't financially stable, I can't help but think,
"What's the point of financial stability,
if you're miserable?"
You can totally have a day job
and pursue what you really want to do
at the same time.
There's a lot I want to say on this topic,
and a lot of unique situations that I can't speak to,
but ultimately what I took away
from the whole conversation was,
What's the point of living if
you're not chasing your dreams?
No matter how grand they are.
Hey!
Marvel, how's it going?
So I heard uh, you got all these like,
TV shows and movies, that's really cool,
Uh, I just wanted to put myself on your radar
you know, cause I haven't seen like,
an Asian female superhero, you kno- you know?
I'm--I'm Cindy Moon.
Silk?
You know, I was bit by the same spider
as Peter Parker?
HEY MARVEL!
Don't you fucking ignore me, motherfucker, okay?
I'm here in Hollywood and I'm here to stay, okay?
I'm here for that representation, motherfucker,
YOU GOT ME?!
(beep)
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
I want to say thank you to Squarespace
for sponsoring today's episode.
The sites look professionally designed,
regardless of your super level,
and the tools are intuitive and easy to use!
And if you sign up for a year, you get a free domain.
Listen to your spidey-senses.
Go to squarespace.com to start your free trial today,
and use the offer code "ANNA"
for 10% off your first purchase.
Squarespace.
With great power comes great responsibility.